by the way David do you know that no
judge in the United States has looked at
the evidence from the 2020 election that
is not my understanding no it's a
hundred percent they've kicked him all
out for standing everyone if you find
one that has looked at the evidence
David you call me I'll give you as many
pillars as you want for your whole
audience don't judge has looked at the
evidence I will do it kicked it out for
standing every single one I will find it
none of them have kicked it out on mayor
CEO and inventor of my pillow uh we are
gonna take a moment to recover here from
the extremely high level of energy uh
Mike it's always fascinating to talk to
you I really do appreciate your time and
and hope to speak to you again and I
appreciate you having me on your show
you guys are you guys I would come on
anytime it's a shame that no one's let
anybody on Fox news or Newsmax I agree
David you know I enjoy your little
machine sarcasm don't give me they
should have you on